[Music]
Ava Mendes is older brother has lost his
battle with throat cancer
Juan Carlos Mendes was diagnosed with
cancer a year and a half ago he died on
April 17th at the age of 53 the Mendes
is celebrated his life on Tuesday
Ava's younger brother Carlo posted this
photo of the program and wrote in part
quote I still can't believe this has
happened I'm crying as I write this and
I have no idea how to cope with him
being gone the 42 year old actress has
shared her own posts about her brother
including this picture of them together
earlier this month in this Instagram
post Carlo wrote that their brother past
quote peacefully and said quote he
fought with all his might and power and
gave cancer one hell of a fight Ava
spoke about her brother's battle at last
year stand up to cancer event each one
of us in this room that is here tonight
we're here because someone in our family
or someone close to us has been affected
by this insidious disease tonight I'm
here with my family and my brother
Carlos who I love so much